[Music]
is it wrong news
I believe so it is always wrong hmm I'm
a man of morals and it's always wrong
submitted by Chris Hanson oh he likes to
catch pedophiles why don't you take a
seat what is that that's it
Dateline NBC how to catch a predator
oh that guy what's he doing now making
songs you got maybe he's catching
predators he's dead undercover yeah the
internet is not happy about me Lee Bobby
Brown & Drink texting texting yeah
that's kind of weird
yeah Drake 11 and Drake yeah thing
sexually or just regular text yeah what
does that mean
whoo how did this happen wait wait let's
thing about this didn't merely Bobby
Brown post a text message with Drake no
okay I would text her I'll be like dude
how was it on set like I'm so excited
I'm like a fan you know I would text I'm
like I got the same nose problem my [ __ ]
bleeds all the time and I'd be like I'd
be like how long did it take you to grow
your hair back okay wait then you guys
think about this
imagine what would it be weird if any of
us were texting Joe Josie why she's like
60 she just did a big music video I mean
like a concert right yeah me too she's
like six feet tall yeah she's huge like
I feel like though if you're an artist
all of like the regular social stigma is
off because artists collab alot so
you're you're you're connecting on an
artistic and creative level especially
if you're at a high level so like that
Nellie Brown she's an actress right out
of high level drinks the rapper at a
high level and they're probably just
talking about art or whatever oh he used
to be an actor - yeah so there's that
but then um but if there's something
that is sexual image that's romantic
that's really or romantic that's weird I
like chatting with people old and young
or whatever and I think what connects me
is
hobbies what if it was just something
like hey Drake I like like I'm such a
big fan of your music I'm so like
honored to be talking to you and he's
like oh damn that's tired I like
watching stranger things - I don't know
why yeah he could be like a mentor or
kind of a fan of stranger things like
we're all fans of stranger how fabulous
I think that's what it is
I'll be like guess who I'm texting with
so Millie Bobby Brown was on the red
carpet at the Emmys and she was talking
to Access Hollywood about Dre yeah so
this is the video of her interview oh
gosh I love him I met him in Australia
and he's honestly so fantastic and a
great friend and a great great role
model you know we Texas I'm definitely
gonna go and see him I'm so excited yeah
you know it sounds like grooming what's
what's grooming do y'all remember when
we did that article about the guy in
China that was the music teacher for the
young girl yeah and it ended up falling
in love and he started in the article it
said he started off talking to her about
boys he was like if you have problems
with boys talk to me so that is we me
like it's like if someone was like I
don't know like let's say like if I was
texting her and we're talking about
stranger things and I'm asking her about
like acting and all this stuff right and
she starts talking to me about like her
relationships I'm like oh I don't talk
well what do you say let's say she gets
comfortable and she goes I've been
talking to this guy oh like if she
confides in me you
I'll be like okay but if anyone if
anyone starts talking to me about that
kind of stuff I don't really want to
hear it unless it's my close friends
yeah okay I mean some people they they
don't mind talking about it like they'll
be like come here like some people are
very like what do you call it warm and
inviting and they'll listen David yeah
and it for me I'm like unless I really
care about you I don't want to listen to
it because it just burdens me yeah it's
like why would I want to deal with
someone's boy problems yeah or girl
problems like there's got to be a
connect a so wait yo in Tim thing about
this based off what we just saw from a
girl's perspective did it not sound like
she was a little excited to be talking
to Jay I mean I think it also could be
from her cuz she she did come out saying
that she was a fan of his for a long
time something like really young oh so
it could be from like the fan
perspective of like oh my god I can't
believe her friends yeah it's something
about I just felt like really excited to
me that's all I think his girl isn't
Drake's girlfriend like 18 so that so
recently Drake made headlines saying
that he bought out an entire restaurant
to to have a date night with this girl
named Bella yeah yeah she's 18 years old
she's a model she's the daughter of
Jimmy Jam who's a music producer and she
also posted on Instagram
a while back back young [ __ ] is hard to
resist wait though I have a question
after this three weeks ago she posted
this photo beautiful she's pretty she
just came likes - 4 year-olds another
yeah she knows no place I'd rather be
and then so all these reports came out
saying that she was having dinner with
him and she's 18 though yeah but he was
like 31 or 32 or something
31 that's why me but it's legal it's
just it's just weird it is weird but
she's also beautiful wasn't he was it
before we move on I just want to clarify
that she denied being there that she was
in New York the entire time as she did
not have dinner with him in DC wasn't he
reportedly dating and this could just be
me like looking at [ __ ] like
not really paying attention but wasn't
he dating the Kardashian mom a little
bit like wasn't there like a rumor yeah
ooh he was kind of hanging out with her
life that I remember too but there's so
many rumors around his Jenner I'm like
damn he's all over the place he likes
the young girls he likes he's
open-minded no just the mom I think
drink like stuff ugh that's what I'm
thinking I think so you try to kiss me
on on stage remember yeah I think he
also recently tried to ask out um okay
uh Klum what Heidi Klum but then that
she just oh yes she didn't text him back
take them back
yeah she's also she's dating somebody -
though I think it's good she said she
had a crush on Drake on The Ellen Show
why am i so up to date with like he's a
younger Drake
no oh dude yeah he's like they had a kid
together multiple kids yeah what like
that would be interesting I've been
doing good what if they came out with a
seal scar yeah like yeah he's like some
kind of like I just googled this the
other day what the scars on his face
were he had four kid what what are they
look like it was it is needed to a big
fight it's a form of something that like
a genetic or something huh yeah it was
an extreme form of eczema Wow
I thought it was always cool because if
he looked like a like African pirate you
know like he went through some [ __ ] with
a soft voice
you look pretty cool yeah I like the
scar I mean I have this confidence like
this is or about him down there big now
yeah hey whoa let me see you both
probably bigger than me that's tired
yeah our people and outraged saying like
Jake's a pedophile
oh yeah a lot of people on Twitter are
like what the [ __ ] that's not right he's
grooming her that doesn't sound like an
old machine 14 I think one thing that
does uh feel weird is so I follow up
unto the stranger things cast I'm just a
fan of the show but I don't know if it's
her PR team or if it's
what she wants yeah like she dresses
much older than her age and I don't know
if it's a Hollywood being like hey you
want to look more professional you could
probably get more perfume deals or purse
deals that way they're trying to like
pivot her like start transitioning her
and olders yes so I don't really know
what the actual play is but for me just
knowing that she was like 12 or 13 and
then having lipstick and eye shadow and
all this crazy like dress up and it
makes me feel kind of weird that it's
it's also today like if you notice girls
their makeup is on point like high
school girls are doing it right we're
like yeah like I remember like junior
high and high school or whatever like
girls make and in the way you do a young
girls makeup to looked young like if you
if you went to the mall and in a in a
high school girl got makeup done by one
of the artists they were doing it like
she was a kid
yes you wouldn't but then now like
everyone's on point like looking like
cover girls and [ __ ] yeah and the [ __ ]
that they wear - it's a lot more
revealing and I felt I sound like an old
ass [ __ ] because that's what they're
saying about our generation like googles
and booty shorts or whatever but I feel
like it's more common now it is it's
that coupled with the posing like
because they have so much access to all
these like I G influencer is a model
because they're learning how to do as
soon as you don't smile anymore that's
some seductive ass [ __ ] so the girls
know that now and they're just like that
booty get likes and they're trying to
have followers like when I was 13 I used
to just like chew up crowns and mix them
with petroleum jelly and then put them
on my eyelids and do my space angles now
they're like the only camera like booty
pop and like everything like I don't
know you guys remember little tight
I remember she posted this one photo
where she had her butt on like a sink or
something like a counter she's - she's
crazy
you know it's like we've been [ __ ]
and acting crazy since 1314 we just
don't realize how young we look yeah
and now we we're like geezers and then
we look at 14-year olds like oh my god
you guys are so young but we were doing
crazy ass [ __ ] too so then this is not
actually looked young look like do you
guys think they should be able to be
that provocative at such a young age ago
do you guys cool with that personally
personally no like if it's if it's my
daughter like let's say Millie Bobby
Brown's my daughter yeah um I would be
monitoring that conversation and then I
would be like okay if if Drake is
telling my daughter he misses her okay I
need to read the string of Texas yeah I
would be a fanboy like watching movies
keyword I totally forgot my man said I
miss you that's weird
daddy's back that's how you - you can't
artists you just like no I think so
going back to you saying like us being
little let's go back to when we were
little girls if an influential person
that we look up to is of the opposite
sex is telling us that they miss us like
you're kind of gonna crush a little bit
although she's thinking like a
fourteen-year-old if she has crushes
she's like Drake is like the ultimate
crush like I bet you even if he doesn't
have feelings for her she's interested
in him and then that's that problem I
have another question for you are you
pointing can't because because it's
directly related to what you just said
he's cutting you being inverted so you
said even if he doesn't have a crush on
her she has a crush on him hmm my direct
question to that is you know the age-old
question what what came first the
chicken or the egg
yeah came first the kid or the pedophile
Phil grabbing key new kids create
pedophiles because they're looking all
hot or the pedophiles groom kids because
because what about what about in the
situations where a teachers just [ __ ]
minding his own business and this girl
got the hots for this teacher and she's
just [ __ ] every single class the the
the shirt gets lower and skirt gets
higher and she's just always dropping
corners in front of the teacher and
[ __ ] she's catalyzing the [ __ ] you
for example all that picturing is uh God
what's a [ __ ] tiara what's her name
the one that dances in in a Kanye West's
video oh yeah Tiana all the super fit
check yeah so that's all I'm thinking
about cuz as you're saying the mo cut or
that's super high like this girl's gotta
be fine so um uh how old is his girl cuz
I'm thinkin high school and like a
senior she looks like a grown [ __ ]
woman with curves titties it's all high
school but she's 16 what do you do you
[ __ ] look away cuz that be legal you
got to be you can't even stand up and
teach cuz you get a boner you can try to
see if we can like transfer her to a
different class no right for the reason
this girl makes me wait too horny
transfer Julie just fire you can I be
honest maybe she's a straight-a student
cuz she wants to impress the [ __ ] out of
you mm-hmm you can't even be honest at
school you're you're not a primitive man
and you're not your dick you have a
brain and you could be like like damn
she fine
oh [ __ ] though she's a baby you and then
you can turn it off that way or you just
don't think about it and then you move
to Russia
[Music]